welcome to this video playing co rock
korek from Norway another English
Defence okay well as my transpose to
something nims Oh Indian like okay let's
see okay well maybe I should have taken
before so that I actually get a spawn
structure damage but that's not a big
deal still still okay like has this nice
Sun set up with the post-it note yeah
where should I take
yeah not sure I take on c3 rooks III am
I play Bishop f3 and even exchange more
of it what can you do Bishop f3 i can go
leave for now
hmm
f-for don't know don't know should I
have a close it's not not very
attractive right okay maybe like this
you can play d5 and cut off my bishop
okay doesn't do it okay it's not the end
of the world like d 595 to you for what
if i take on f3 now if it takes with the
bishop I take you want to deform so it
needs to play a move that's probably not
very desirable rook cheeks but then I
have rookie form I am ok so I get
something going on the e-file yeah it's
not easy for me to coordinate now
let's let's not look nice I would you
see how does here defend this now even
know I'm not easy don't see a good move
yeah hmm yeah I can take be too and
maybe I should take be too but rookie
aid is also very attractive yeah I guess
this is sis's sis's radium getting this
is this optimum pressure on the Evil
Queen D 2 nite c 5 intending oh wow
really that they can afford that
thinking queen be true we are just
attacking me to Queen e7 my community 7
look f2 he is totally tied down
brilliant but the night g6 right all
looks looks excellent but since do this
this also just attacks the Queen side
yeah and this is really I can take the
pawn I can take the pawn simply 95 no
come on I'll take the spoon this is also
the super important pawn because it
after a 595 I get this fantastic night
square it's not just the material but
the the strategic implications edgy for
you can you can play it and want that is
it still it's still a total total
tie-down of whites position
we'd be form yeah but I don't need to
rush things you cannot move any of his
pieces really isn't that tactic now this
looks like nightie for but ok no no need
no need don't need to be in any hurry
here ok b3 is just just collapsing
check yeah this is not losing a rook but
ok this was this was toast anyway white
resides yeah all of a sudden this this
was this was bad here so we had this
queen of six and around here he needs to
be more careful i think yeah the next
move here this this is rook e1 this
leads to you trouble this is not
probably also one of those quick moves
five seconds here yeah why does what is
somewhat under pressure in the center
here and he needs to be precise to to
not be be in trouble Knight g4 Queen d2
are more suggested by the engine yeah
yeah I'm better just like that computer
already suggests Bishop e3 giving up a
pawn now this is even worse now is
totally tied down yeah queen bee to
maybe what's better but this is just
this is terrible I have multiple ways to
do it I think just I made it I played
the lazy good persons version of it but
I just ever kept this it's all minus
five minus five all along he needs to
take but then b3 is falling as well g3
and so on and it's all our weaknesses
now yeah so he had only one careless
move in this game this this rookie won't
move yeah he has some weaknesses in the
center so he must be be careful if he is
he shouldn't be in any danger but it it
went downhill really quickly with with
11 bad move this
p 1 okay thanks for watching